[Música]
minha vida andar por este país para ver
se um dia descanso feliz guardando as
recordações das terras onde passei
andando pelos sertões e dos amigos que
lá deixei a música transforma transforma
pessoas transforma lugares
a música cria laços cria esperança
constrói caráter e ajuda a mudar o mundo
eu nasci em 7 de março de 1980
três anos depois os meus pais se
separaram e eu fui morar com a minha mãe
e minhas três irmãs
nessa viela no jardim florence periferia
da cidade de campinas
minha mãe trabalhava como empregada
doméstica para sustentar casa casa
improvisada com madeiras e lonas
eu me lembro com oito para nove anos de
uma cena minha mãe trazendo parte do
almoço dela para que fosse a nossa janta
foi aí que eu decidi trabalhar então no
contraturno escolar
eu vendia sorvete salgado engraxava o
sapato lavava carros cheguei a trabalhar
tem algumas pequenas empresas
abandonei a escola e minha vida seguiu
assim até os 16 anos quando a minha irmã
mais velha que eu considero a minha
heroína e convidou para assistir uma
apresentação na igreja que ela
frequentava e quando terminou a
apresentação eu tinha certeza que era
isso que eu queria para a minha vida eu
queria a música
o que mais me chamou a atenção além da
música
foi quando terminou e aqueles jovens que
estavam tocando estavam conversando se
alegrando e eu que era um menino muito
tímido com baixa autoestima e ali uma
possibilidade de mudar a minha vida eu
só queria existir
eu me considerava só mais um menino
negro pobre invisível e esquecido como
tantos outros meninos nas periferias do
nosso país então investir um pouco de
dinheiro que eu tinha
frei um teclado parcelado e foi pra
minha casa
convenci convencer a minha mãe e minhas
irmãs que eu seria o primeiro músico da
família
eu tocava o tempo todo andava com um
teclado pra cima e pra baixo e isso
chamou a atenção de outros meninos vendo
aquele instrumento também se
interessaram pela música e nós decidimos
formar uma banda banda intitulada banda
a melo anello significa desejo vontade
inspiração e começávamos a tocar nas
escolas do bairro campos de futebol
em alguns momentos nós até local vamos o
som tocava em cima de um caminhão com o
nosso palco com a ajuda dos comerciantes
do bairro que nós anunciamos no durante
o show o comércio que tinha apoiado
aquela apresentação
paralelamente a isso eu comecei a
ensinar o pouco que eu estava aprendendo
sozinho e pela primeira vez tinha
crianças adolescentes jovens descendo
freqüentando a viela que eu freqüentava
porque não ia pessoas na viela eu tinha
vergonha da onde eu morava
eu achava que não tinha nada para
oferecer mas agora não importava mais a
música morava dentro de mim e o espaço
se tornou pequeno e pouco tempo porque
era muita gente querendo aprender ea
saída foi colocar um espaço maior no
próprio bairro
no início de 2000 eu coloquei esse salão
com a ajuda dos comerciantes que
apoiavam a locação do som e foi um
recorde porque tinha muita gente
querendo aprender muita gente querendo
ter essa experiência com com a música e
algo que eu só consegui dar conta porque
vieram outros músicos outras pessoas
também apaixonadas em compartilhar eram
músicos autodidatas outros que tinham um
pouco mais de conhecimento e dentre
esses músicos um baterista chamado
paulinho alves
no finalzinho de dezembro como um
presente de natal ele me convidou para
assistir uma apresentação e eu disse sim
uma apresentação pode
da vida de alguém imagine duas ele me
disse lucas vai ter um trio de música
instrumental brasileira o jazz
brasileiro tocando repertório sair com
hermeto pascoal nome segue aberto
desmonte tom jobim em tom tantos outros
músicos é e que eu não conhecia e sim
vamos chegando lá a nossa estratégia é o
seguinte nós só tínhamos o dinheiro da
passagem
então era pra chegar clube chega bem
próximo do palco pra que a gente não
tiver que conversar com versão né
não tínhamos dinheiro para consumir e
nós estávamos tão próximos que em uma
das pausas que os músicos fizeram para
um trio de jazz tocando talvez e
pianista e ele na pausa ele acabou
pisando em um dos fios e desconectou e
eu me ofereci pra consertar e no final
da apresentação de falar comigo e me
agradecer perguntar qual era a minha
relação com a música eu disse que eu
estava aprendendo a tocar teclado e que
iniciando um projeto social ele disse
que era o sonho também da vida dele
fazer parte de um projeto como esse eo
convidei então vamos em um mês depois
ele estava no jardim florence
inaugurando a primeira banda de jazz e
de música instrumental brasileira na
periferia da cidade de campinas junto
uma pessoa boa traz atrai outras né
junto com guilherme vieram outras
pessoas
muitos outros músicos pessoas nos ajudar
na área administrativa pessoas nos
ajudará a a pagar o aluguel a da aula
enfim era muita gente chegando
e dentre essas pessoas vêm a musicista
carol vivaldi quer me ver tocando
teclado foi lucas você tem talento você
já tocou em um piano foi não nunca
toquei no piano na minha vida
flora estou saindo de casa e você
poderia utilizar o piano vai ficar na
casa da minha mãe ela teria o prazer de
receber e eu topei faleciam criar o tse
quero sim eu freqüentava a casa da mãe
da carol sandra vivaldi de uma a três
vezes por semana
essa é sandra ela me dava café da manhã
lanche da manhã e almoço foi a primeira
vez assim três refeições em menos de
quatro horas
sabe muito especial foi nossa sinta
classe média vive interessante e quero
ser também e mas não foi só isso e com o
passar do tempo um ano depois de um ano
e meio ela me provocou dizendo lucas
você tocando bem piano porque você não
presta o conservatório de tatuí
eu disse sandra eu tenho um problema ela
qual o problema eu só tenho até a 5ª
série
ela disse eu tenho a solução mas depende
de você eu sou professora aposentada e
serei a sua professora particular e se
você voltar a estudar conquistar o seu
diploma naturalmente vai ter que fazer
um supletivo e prestar o conservatório
passar eu irei apoiar você todos os anos
porque teria uma distância né pra e até
o conservatório e montar alguns momentos
hospedagem alimentação e eu topei o
desafio e foi isso o que aconteceu em
2004 estava ingressando no conservatório
de tatuí onde
é transformar mudou a minha vida
não não só a minha vida mas a vida de
mais de 3.500 alunos 3.800 alunos que
passaram pelo nosso projeto pelo
instituto nelo e também à comunidade
porque o florence
se vocês quiserem pesquisar jardim
florence campinas
antes da música era só a páginas
policiais agora a gente estava na
páginas de cultura da cidade
a música transformando muitas vidas eu
percebi eu só queria resisti que a
música também me fazer resistir a tanta
desigualdade que nós temos no nosso país
então assim for muito assim oportunidade
compartilhada com muita gente
o músico se tornando o menino se
tornando profissionais tocando em
programas de tv tocando o cenário do
jazz música pop gravando com artistas e
mudou a vida de muitas pessoas eu teria
muitas histórias pra compartilhar com
vocês mas eu separei uma é eu estava bem
encaminhado para as aulas de piano e diz
que aparece a dona zulmira a dona
zulmira me apareceu e falou olha eu
tenho um menino um filho chamado levy e
o sonho dele aprender a tocar violão e
eu levy é foi indicado pela psicóloga e
assistente social do bairro eu vim da
roça eu sou empregada doméstica e mora
na periferia a o eu separei do marido ea
só eu trabalhando para sustentar levy e
três filhas
eu falei ela tá contando a minha
história porque essa é a minha história
me identifiquei na hora
fizemos a matrícula de levi começaria na
semana seguinte
só que todo mundo era voluntário e o
professor que dava aula ele precisou se
ausentar foi morar em uma outra cidade
antes de iniciar a primeira aula do levy
conclui a falar não com rostinho bonito
de se ver e eu falei fiquei sem saber o
que fazer
as oportunidades aparecem mas os
desafios também então eu fui estudar eu
não fazia uma aula da aula com o bebê
para fazer uma aula da mala com levy e
ficou assim o conteúdo torres galera
dois instrumentos agora eu estava
tocando quando você se abre uma
possibilidade e teve uma entrevista
foi uma emissora de tv entrevistar e
olive falou que ela ficou com soluções
que nem entrevistas crianças né
além disso meu sonho é ser professor
daniel lucas foi aí eu pensei antes da
música eu tive certeza que transforma a
minha vida porque antes da música nenhum
eu queria ser igual a mim né
então eu olhei que agora me tornar uma
referência pra alguém da mesma maneira
que o guilherme ribeiro era minha
referência que é sandra a gabriela
dentre outros voluntários que passaram
por ali músicos pessoas voluntários
gente interessada em fazer aquilo
acontecer assim aquilo foi impactante
para mim eu vi o levi crescendo se
desenvolvendo se tornando o professor
levi se tornou professor e eu vejo o
bebê voando cada vez mais alto falando
em voa em 2015
nós recebemos o primeiro convite pra
voar
nós fomos indicados com arshavin e as
festival itália é e uma novidade para
todo mundo eu nunca tinha entrado no
avião que tinha saído do estado de são
paulo né
então foi assim algo assim os moradores
do bairro eles passavam na frente da
instituição
boa sorte sabe aquela coisa linda assim
de autoestima pra pra tudo aquilo porque
quando não tinha música onde não tem
cultura a violência ver o espetáculo
então nós tínhamos nós tínhamos ali um
cenário totalmente diferente e eu
cheguei na minha mãe para pedir a bênção
como de costume para a mãe voar pela
primeira vez um grupo de alunos e
professores do anel
nós já enviamos para a itália gente mas
de foram 28 pessoas
esse ano nós temos o desafio de embarcar
novamente e pela primeira vez além da
itália nós vamos participar de um
festival de jazz na áfrica do sul
detalhe sem patrocínios músicos vendem
pizza fazem rifa
em tóquio pela cidade para arrecadar
fundos e nós temos o desafio de enviar
este ano mais 12 pessoas vocês para cada
festival e eu falei mãe roboearth filho
mas não é perigoso é melhor seguir de
ônibus
eu falei mãe não dá não dá não dar da
praia do navio mas porque sabem que
demoram dez dias 7 ela fosse tá bom
então vai com deus que vai dar tudo
certo realmente deu tudo certo
o título virou notícia internacional a
notícia na itália nós tivemos o cuidado
de tocar em estúdios na rádio rai por
exemplo em coma
chega lá tem foto de de chico buarque
toquinho das músicas são referências
assim pra gente né então foram muitas
conquistas mas nenhuma foi fácil mas
cada uma teve o sabor de serem
conquistadas assim passo a passo e com
muito esforço
há oportunidades e desafios e mesmo
vivendo em um país onde não se investe
em cultura e arte educação eu o bebê
o guilherme e todos se vão tocar
i e ii
raul e
alguém aí
a oea
alê
há um erro
não tá pai
e eu dispenso feliz quadras em ações das
terras onde passei
andando pelos sertões e dos amigos que
lá deixei o chão vai só
a poeira e carvão
longe de casa siga o roteiro mais um
mais taça ii
ea saudade no coração
el e mal e raul e raul é
a lei real e real e opel e
our own errar
a opel é el e a ua